Oh
has already been beaten bloody
enough for the protesters this was
savage cornered and alone more violence
plain and simple
but the protester medics came to his aid
other protesters told me he'd assaulted
someone first before their attack but
here he's saying I chanted Hong Kong as
keep going
[Applause]
medics lieutenant in but you can see the
level to get me up to the cloud his face
has been beaten to the absolute Pole
there's still his shouting abuse to him
even as he's receiving medical attention
from people who look like that with the
protesters this is just a Sunday
afternoon animal but it was the same
[Applause]
the protesters complain about excessive
force by police they are more than
capable of it themselves it started as a
peaceful occupation of this shopping
center then they showed what they
thought of the Chinese motherland
trashing the national flag
this is a site that infuriates Beijing
but it became less and less about
political protest hooliganism instead
[Applause]
and it sometimes appeared paradoxical
one man smashing a screen while a woman
sweeps up the wreckage eventually the
police tried to storm the shopping
center the protestors prepared their
barricades pouring oil and water onto
the floor to make it slippy
this is what they've done this weekend
provoke a confrontation then retreat
there are bigger protests planned over
the next 10 days and they want to avoid
arrest outside they set a fire to catch
the authorities attention after hours of
chaos the police finally mustered in
force
they fired tear gas looking on though it
was hard to see exactly what they were
aiming at because when they advanced the
protesters had already gone ready to
fight another day
very soon Tom Cheshire Sky News Hong
Kong